hey how's it going bros my name is
pewdiepie and welcome to
friday's my part
on an actual friday for the first time
we did it
[Music]
it's wow to me
me having a rough week steve from blue's
clues telling me he never forgot me i
don't get it
average parallel universe theory fed
average food and sleeping
hey guys
wake up
at least in another parallel universe
edgar isn't sleepy
maybe he even understands parts of it
[Music]
that was such a fun video uh mark korean
felix swedish jack irish what does that
spell ksi illumina to confirm well what
if this changes my life in every way
thank you a bunch of nerds keep
commenting saying that i look like
pewdiepie he [ __ ] does and it's weird
as hell i've seen them before so this is
my best impersonation of pewdiepie here
we go okay i don't remember what you've
never played tuba simulator
what you've never played super simulator
today is felix cake day and he turned
nine year old on reddit wow thanks guys
that's huge
wow
everything's different now
oh my god that's actually unreal holy
cow whoa
god damn
beautiful
beautiful that's kind of taking at least
six thousand hours unironically
big ups
big peepee oh this is the steve guy
thank you steve and then look at you
look at all you have become and all you
have
chief steve i
don't know that frappe you are but i
appreciate it my
what a real guy what a nice guy that
steve guy is dormant calling out pewds
in his video for saying that dormant
videos are bad
pewter's making two more videos
oh man do you think he'll actually make
one
like a mr b the one he did for mr beast
but with me
we'll see
pewdiepie multiverse we have regular
pewdiepie scruffy as [ __ ] looking
pewdiepie and the
no it's not racist i'm doing a voice
girlfriend hahaha you forgot the space
there buddy thanks for being my best
friend happy national girlfriend day
it's a sad story laughter you know
is it i mean this guy is clearly a creep
this is dumb it's all dumb it's not a
sad story it's a dumb story and i laugh
at it as well ha
that's hella cute look at that dog
that's a cute dog make this comment
section edgar search history all right
let's see what i guess been looking up
how to take over my father's youtube
channel oh my god
speaking of taking over things all right
i had a massive epiphany this is huge
this is [ __ ] huge i was looking into
don't ask why i wasn't looking into what
territories norway have right because i
was curious for no reason it turns out
[ __ ] norway owns a piece of
antarctica what is this day wait just
stay with me here stay with me here here
we go here we go okay yeah look at this
see this chili
okay friends norway has a huge piece
what is it and then you're like but what
is this what is white no one owns the
white part of antarctica are you getting
this if
norway can grab such a huge piece then i
felix kejellberg leader of bro army
that's right army nation we are taking
antarctica it's mine now at first i will
just
make people believe it's mine kind of
like i don't like comparing myself to
china but i think you know where i'm
going okay it's mine okay i'm saying
that it's mine you believe me that's
right antarctica is mine i will share
with you if you say that it's mine thank
you antarctica is mine it's mine now
it's unclaimed at least i'm not stepping
on anyone's toes right it's mine now how
do i take antarctica because i kind of
want to take it more than just saying
that it's mine how to claim i'm sure
someone's made a how-to on this making
claims
um how do you claim here we go all right
oh it's the guardian
modern claims are not made with flags or
brass cylinders
papers lodged with the un ah get out of
here
i don't have time for that okay i'm
gonna look more into this but i would
until then and darth again it's it's
ours
pewdiepie
avoiding controversies this year be like
uh no it ends now because antarctica
mine is mine okay i don't care if it's
controversy i will have it i want it it
will be like that one anime where they
go to antarctica right they made an
anime about that for some reason i don't
know why listen this could be us we
could be total nine-year-old anime i'm
sure no one will freeze today i think
this is probably the best idea i've ever
had even though japan thought of it
first i'm executing it pewter whenever
he talks about the tragic death of
warship it's a sad story
[Laughter]
love this mean template keep it up
nothing just pierce in his thumbnail you
are correct sir that is me i'm just
chilling with my homie oh yeah austin
bradley oh my god did i address this
already i literally can't remember
austin bradley friend friend of the fam
i don't know what to call it this
[ __ ] guy made a face reveal and i
just berated him
where is that i feel so bad
oh god there he is
dude i'm so dumb he was just trying to
be funny and i'm like shut the [ __ ] up
about the camera all right
what a beautiful guy love it i'm sorry
man
uh but yeah he's he's working on a 3d
printed version i think that'd be say uh
swedish city names umio stockholm
british city names gloshester
i cannot say it
wolverhampton wolverhampton new key
light fire
of grinding girl the fan for yeah
myanmar went to wales recently i always
thought my last name shelburg was weird
right it ain't weird try and read any
any city name in wales oh my god oh my
god
let fairfield
bro you have to add some nouns in there
or whatever it's called
oh sure
sure buddy sure whales isn't real you
know what where's this mine now so no
i'll hold up i'll i'll let wales i'll
let wells be until now that was
beautiful though i just realized i'm
looking at austin bradley's he has so
many popular uploads i don't even
realize what a legend yeah he's making
adventures now
[ __ ] hey yeah he's awesome did you
download cheaper simulator yes what did
it cost nothing and that's a great price
what a wonderful photoshop you did there
that looks that looks
amazing thank you so much sunday with
pewdiepie while he is still in the uk he
plays yeah once he does assignments on
they might never be we should we do need
to give him ideas like he doesn't like
us we did it among us with him and he
could tell he was just kind of fed up
with us
no no
dude i love cyber reacts come on please
[ __ ] now i feel i didn't see this and
because i asked if i i was available at
a date and i couldn't do it but i would
love to do it i love sight sidemen
yeah
i'm just awkward i'd say
hell yeah hell yeah
pewd's not laughing at a meme cyber who
said the clips
that's good
it's interesting how that works right oh
man
why why are people ripping into this guy
he was such a good actor i thought why
why are people being mean to him yeah
he's got shitty material to work with
but he did a good job i think they all
did what is this if i guess
can you guess what this pewdiepie porter
is made out of
oh
um
it's black and white
no not really not fully black and white
let's get tints of purple in it i don't
know
it could be minecraft could be a rubik's
cubes i don't think it is uh no that's
no way it's too big oh it's interesting
it's rendered this way right from top
way down
maybe some sort of paper notes
it's made out of magnets
all right 25 000 magnets
i love i love the way you made us guess
i'm not gonna lie that's fun
all right
i got you homie oh okay
hell yeah don't god damn it
oh yeah look at that scoop i mean it's
not great but
it works
yeah i mean can't you literally you know
do the same thing like any other
screwdriver all right thanks for
uploading man that's big pp
ah yes the man with 110 million subs yes
cheers guys and owner of antarctica
what do you say what should we do to
celebrate this glorious victory of
antarctica
no no
are you serious
no
that is not funny i can't even spell
norwegian that's how dumb norwegian is
no
[Applause]
that [ __ ] damn it
i can't be
it's whatever it's whatever it's
whatever yeah yeah he goes
i'm done bye smash like subscribe
antarctica mine remember
slash smash like subscribe antarctica
mine
yeah that rhymes you thought it was gay
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator add some of our
patented stickers in there stickers our
emotions means our emotions express your
emotions with me
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time full circle
baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this